foreign
we all have crazy family members if you
think you don't that means it's you
just keep that in mind all right that's
how we know this all right so but and I
John lately I've been getting
like in the last week I've gotten five
emails
from prominent
people that I am friends with
asking me if the banks are going to
collapse
and these are people that I would have
thought
wouldn't have thought that all but one
man he pretty much believes all the
conspiracy theories but yeah but the uh
or the world's coming to an end or
whatever and it's all Joe Biden's fault
and all that kind of stuff right so but
but the other guys are like I'm like
you're really
really and I have to send them a nice
email back
assuring them
that were okay and Warren Buffett comes
out this week and says uh
Berkshire Hathaway Berkshire Hathaway
his company's annual meeting he
suggested fear is contagious and
consumers fears about the safety of
their banking institutions are making it
hard to respond to the crisis
effectively because the people in the
banking world and in the government have
done such a poor job of messaging what's
really going on that was Buffett's point
and it's it's causing fear to be
contagious now we ran into I think
during
um covid that fear was more contagious
than covet was correct
and more contagious than the fear was
the financial incentive for media
companies to spread fear
that is their that's how they get paid
and so I I think what he I think he's
calling out something that's really
important we're herd animals so fear is
contagious that's how we've survived as
a species if somebody starts running we
all just start running with them right
but if you have an entire banking
industry an entire media industry an
entire all everybody telling you run run
all the time I went out the back door
there was five deer standing there and
uh one of them got spooked and the other
four are going we're running but why are
we running
we like to think we're sophisticated
Dave our brains are operating at that
level when we are scared we're running
but I don't know why I don't know why
we're running why are we pulling up
everything's going to go listen we're
going to die I think he calls something
out important here it used to be up
until very recently you had to get in
your car and drive down and look at your
banker and say I want to take all my
money out and they would say that's dumb
and they could calm you down now I can
just go online in the with the glow and
pull it all out and so he is right there
is this moment now when we can all be
stupid and there's no guard rails on our
stupidity yeah right you know and so I I
I'm calling Dave I I'm almost begging
there has to be some group of people
that are running the news stations that
have to have a moment of conscience to
say we've got to stop and I know it
sells tickets I get it but we've got to
come up with another way than just
trying to get people to panic because
it's going to run us all off a cliff
it just is hit the fair porn the fear
off the media is driving this and fear
is contagious so other than getting the
media to behave because I still think
they're probably going to yell at us
that we're all going to die of a tornado
by Nightfall but um you're gonna die
it's just a god it's hilarious I'm not
like yeah probably not
um probably not gonna die I'm you know
and if I do guess what I'm dead
whatever yeah but um I'm going with this
I'm sticking with it so you know the if
the media is not going to turn off the
fear porn
fear is contagious correct how do we
what are some things that the average
the typical person can do
to calm and go wait a minute
so uh I I think I've talked about this
with you privately
um when I was in 2008 2009 2010 when the
the other banking crisis happened and I
was just anxious out of my mind I sat
down with a guy who's Works in banking
and I just hammering him hammering him
and he got me to a point the facts are
your friends facts your friends here's
what he said he said John if you take
all of your money out of the bank and
all of the banks implode your money is
absolutely worthless and his quote was
so fantastic he said your neighbor will
be coming over to hunt you for your
water it's a different ball game so the
idea that you're going to save yourself
by doing a thing is false that's that's
it's not truthful it's not a fact so the
greatest thing you can do is leave your
stuff alone leave your stuff alone and
that's just again looking at facts I
think I think the the answer to if is
fear contagious how do you
keep from Catching it
one is you just take a turn off
everything yeah turn off the stupid
television but the news channels but the
uh the second thing is facts are your
friends right okay and everything that's
on the internet is not a fact correct
um everything that's on the internet is
not true Abraham Lincoln said that okay
so um you know that's uh you know so you
know that these things so just because
your conspiracy
uh Theory friend Rachel Cruz says that
this is going to occur does not mean
that it's actually going to occur as a
matter of fact it's a high probability
if you're conspiracy friends thinking
it's going to happen that they're wrong
correct very high probability correct
and play taking the facts of your
friends take it all the way out you have
twenty five thousand dollars in cash in
in a box and the U.S banking system
implodes
that will be good for kindling right I
mean kenneling yeah you can start a
firework we can start a fire what are
you actually going to do yeah right
exactly and so hang in there there's a
whole bunch of other people that have
way more money that have a vested
interest in this thing working out so be
still and be slow and turn turn The the
chaos off your T off your devices
um so so number one is stop your inputs
uh whether they be conspiracy theories
or media channels this number two is sit
down and calmly think about and even
write down
what the real facts of the situation are
not what the rumors or the emotions are
because the feelings will lie to you
right and you have a supernatural
ability to do this Dave I don't I have
to call a friend that I trust and say
hey man I'm spun up on this can you give
me some wisdom that's what my buddies
are doing to me I guess
that are emailing me going oh there's
another bank failed are we going no
we're not it's just a bad bank I mean
and you know and there's some stupid
people in the banking World here's the
thing
I have observed this and here's a fact
for you out there if you're worried if
you are got a little of this uh you
caught this contagious fear bug okay
here's a fact for you I've noticed that
you're gonna love this from higher
education
um
it Financial downturns run on this
Rhythm and this cycle
when the current crop of mbas
gets to 38 years old
and has no memory of the last stupid
stuff they repeat it and calls the next
one correct and so there's a rhythm they
don't have any institutional memory
because they don't have a memory they
weren't there when we survived 2008 so
now here we are eight years later you
know and six years later and now we're
on that Rhythm the people that didn't
okay I survived 2008 I made a lot of
money in 2008 when everything turned
down because I bought a lot of stuff
while it was down real estate and mutual
funds both were down it was a great
buying opportunity and everything I
bought in those days has doubled and so
yeah I made a ton of money yeah and so
my institutional memory is long because
I'm old right and but but you know the
the people making stupid butt decisions
like loaning people money to buy a house
who are broke
when broke people buy houses and we sell
them millions of them you're gonna break
the economy correct because they can't
pay the bill stupid correct you know but
when you get a group of people who don't
remember that from 2008 they're gonna do
it again
because that new crop of mbas turns 38
and they don't remember the last one
they they replicate the problems and
that's a lot of what you're seeing with
these Bankers right now they're stupid
but horrible practices in a particular
bank because they don't because a 38
year old that doesn't remember 2008.
wasn't functioning in their role in 2008
is now making the similar mistakes and
that's what's happening so you're okay
we're okay people it's a normal rhythm
of dumb butt mbas this is the Ramsay
show